♪
I’ve waited
Maxine: my entire life to arrive.
Maxine: But arriving is not the end of the journey,
Maxine: it’s just the beginning.
♪
Pierre: You are?
Benjamin Franklin, ma’am.
Napoleon.
Maxine Simmons.
Who?
♪
John: This could change things.
Lucien: Creation is our way forward.
♪
Melonie: There’s more to you than meets the eye.
Dusty: There are endless possibilities out there.
♪
Mmm, what flavor is this?
Gin.
That’s what I’m tasting.
Edward: Do we have an alliance?
We have a battle.
♪
Soldier: Long live the Emperor!
Maddie: I was the first to see her dead.
Maddie: They say you were the last to see her alive.
Rusty: You are the best lawyer that I know,
and I need you.
♪
John: I was born with the chance to be somebody.
Daniela: Our existence is all about choices.
♪
Maxine: I am not in over my head.
It would be disrespectful to my hairdresser.
♪
Yeah that’s quite impressive.
We’re doing this!
♪